the crisis over ukraine the u.s says
russia is increasing its forces
surrounding the country not cutting back
on them adding 7 000 more troops in
recent days new satellite images show a
temporary bridge of the type used by
soldiers on the move russia also appears
to be setting up new field hospitals as
if it expects a war in eastern ukraine
officials accuse russian-backed forces
of shelling a village damaging this
kindergarten charlie dagetta is in
western ukraine charlie good morning
good morning to you michelle the fact is
these skirmishes happen almost every day
in that region and it's been going on
for years but at the moment anything
could be a flash point which is why the
message to americans in ukraine this
morning could not be clear
get out now before hostilities start
warren's top u.s diplomat christina
covine the situation could worsen very
quickly and we're very worried about
that and are urging all americans to
leave the country now made more urgent
by those satellite images appearing to
show even more russian forces including
a new pontoon bridge just a few miles
from the border with ukraine the u.s
embassy in keeves shut down and
relocated a core team to an undisclosed
location here on monday we're going to
do everything we can to help american
citizens
we've been working very closely with
other
humanitarian organizations that might
help with flows of not just americans
frankly but but ukrainians as well
families have already begun to flee
eastern ukraine natalya and alexi
brought their young children here from
kharkiv around 30 miles in the russian
border
and what made you decide to that now is
the time to go
it's not rather comfortable to sit at
home with two children and await
something unusual
nobody here in la vie wants to see a war
but the city's mayor says they're ready
if the war breaks out and it's a
full-scale invasion are you prepared to
take in
it is my duty
it is
responsibility in my city and i open my
door i open my my my home
the entire city is opening its home but
praying it doesn't come to that
now we're told that city workers have
been encouraged to take up firearms
training and medical training and
they've stockpiled about three months
worth of medical supplies
tony
and we watch and we wait charlie daggett
in ukraine charlie thank you very much